le projet la cité du rhum et pour la
filière la bonne occasion de donner
vraiment une dimension mondiale aux roms
de la martinique nous sommes déjà
présents dans 100 pays dans le monde
et l'idée c'est de concrétiser cela au
travers d'un bâtiment une structure de
valorisation de l'ensemble du territoire
la martinique et du savoir-faire
martiniquais c'est un projet de
territoire donc c'est un projet qui doit
être partagé et c'est un projet qui doit
avoir le soutien des politiques donc il
était important que nous puissions
présenter cette idée avec les avancées
montrer où en était le projet pour
qu'effectivement les élus puissent nous
donner et nous faire leur retour
nous sommes décidés soutenir ce projet
pour l'instant il s'agit d'une
orientation avec déjà déjà un projet qui
se dessine mais qu'il faut préciser il
faut faire des études
il faut aller plus loin maintenant il va
y avoir une association qui sera créé à
laquelle nous aurons très probablement à
participer et étape après étape je pense
que le projet va se construire
non moi je suis extrêmement intéressé
par ce grand projet pour la matinée